welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us at today's seminar organs on
a chip a revolution in drug development
presented by dr. Gorham Yoder a
scientific director and strategic
science excellence and external
innovation at the Janssen pharmaceutical
companies of Johnson & Johnson my name
is dr. Susie Valdez and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab reduced lab
routes is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box our
speaker will respond to your questions
via email following the presentation if
you have any trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation just click on that ask
a question box and let us know you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and best offers
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits tab
located from the top right corner of
your presentation window and follow the
process for obtaining those credits now
without further ado please join me in
welcoming our presenter today dr. Gore
you order welcome sir thank you I'm very
happy to be able to speak to you today
about technology that I've been looking
at for some time and what I want to do
is is basically give you a description
of that technology and hopefully some
insights on on where that technology can
be applied and and so basically what
I'll do is is give you a brief
introduction about my role at Johnson so
part of that role is is looking at
innovation and looking
new technologies within analytical
development and for the small molecule
organization which I'm a part of and
then I'll get into a more general
description of micro fluidics technology
which is really in my mind a driver for
a lot of technologies that we are
beginning to see and we'll continue to
see in the analytical space and then of
course organs on a chip which is really
the main topic of today which is is
basically a micro fluidics technology
but then combining elements of biology
to that and then I'll get into the
problem statements for biotech and
pharma and then discuss a little bit
about where we are today the next steps
and then some conclusions so first time
what I'll do is I'll describe a little
bit about or give you some thoughts
about science and innovation and and so
you know science is mostly about
evolution and but revolutions do occur
and you know certainly within my career
we've seen a lot of innovation we've
seen a lot of things happen but I would
say for the most part things are very
incremental things are gradually
improving you know new technology
introduces itself and it's it's it's
very much of a continuum but in some
cases you do see some startling changes
and things that do occur in terms of how
we view innovation you know we we
typically look in a longer term you know
10 year horizon and in order to do that
what you have to do is visualize the end
state now where do you want to be in the
next 10 years and so obviously that's a
difficult question for a lot of people
to answer but it has a lot of relevance
I think if you are certainly working in
farm in terms of thinking about what are
the needs for you know the medicines of
tomorrow and some of the new modalities
that we continue to be confronted with
and so oftentimes in the
discussion then we think about creating
a road map or you know sort of it means
to get there and so what I've sort of
put in on this slide it's really kind of
more for fun just to kind of introduce
you to the concept but and certainly you
know most of you have probably studied a
little bit of philosophy in physics and
chemistry and and you know there's
there's been a continual evolution
that's occurred and you know to me
what's striking is that as we sort of
incrementally move forward there's
there's there's always this accumulation
of collected facts and an information
and usually what happens is that you get
a series of anomalies which occur which
then sort of at some point you know when
they reach a critical mass it gets us
into sort of a crises mode where maybe
new theories have to be developed and so
and oftentimes I think it's hard for us
you know scientists to let go of you
know things that we learn in school and
and if applied our whole careers and so
I guess the way I look at innovation is
sort of letting go of certain
preconceived notions and trying to look
forward and trying to determine where I
want to be without really thinking about
ok what are the challenges or what are
the impediments you know just thinking
about what is the future state going to
look like and really thinking out of the
box and trying to you know move forward
so in terms of in terms of revolutions I
mean I think already where we're
experiencing one and and I think most
most people will probably agree with
this is that you know the biggest
revolution going on right now is in data
sciences and so and it's particularly
felt I think you know when you when you
sort of look at you know sort of the
Generation Xers and the Millennials you
know you see this sort of transition
occurring where you know where I'd like
to call going from the analog to digital
world you know suddenly you have the
internet you have social media
and then we're starting to use you know
tools of artificial intelligence and
machine learning you know these are
things now that Facebook and Google and
Microsoft and Apple are using Amazon you
know these are using this on a routine
basis they're generating copious amounts
of information and using that and trying
to predict outcomes and so you know kind
of reflecting on this you know I would
say 20 years ago and I've been in an
industry for a while much of the
technology we see today was maybe
considered science fiction I like to
kind of call these new things science
fiction but what's happening more and
more is that you know we're seeing
technological advances you know really
accelerating I mean it's it's really
pretty incredible now you know what the
digital age is really bringing in terms
of informatics and information and how
we process that information and so
really I think we need again when you're
looking at innovation and looking at
just how scientists need to adapt you're
really confronted with with really one
decision either you go with it or you
you know you get out of your comfort
zone or you know you don't but in the
end I think you have to be bold so so
why do I want to preface this with micro
fluidics technology well I think you
know I sort of prefaced the discussion
with informatics and data and so really
a lot of the expectations right now in
science is that we generate data quicker
more efficiently and so micro fluidics
basically is like technology which can
help the nail enable that and you're
really seeing this start to assert
itself in into the into the research
laboratories and what it basically deals
with is being able to precisely control
behavior manipulate fluids etre that are
really constrained to a small scale and
so basically if you look at let's say
typical analytical and
Instrumentation what we're doing is
really miniaturizing it in many cases to
you know quite a miniature scale or a
chip as we might call it and so this
affords us the opportunity really to
integrate one or more different
analytical functions or protocols within
a single circuit and so this is really
quite amazing and so organs on a chip
that's it's really kind of a logical
successor to this and I'll get into the
you know the specifics around organs on
a chip and a little bit later in the
presentation
but typical advantages of micro fluidics
include the miniaturization of standard
laboratory tools low fluid volume
consumption which means less cost and
waste high throughput which as I
mentioned is important considerations so
that basically translates into faster
analysis and response times due to
shorter diffusion distances and things
like that better process control and
then finally it also is a potential
enabler for medical diagnostics
wearables and biomarkers so what I'm
going to do in the neck for the next few
minutes then this really kind of give
you an introduction of what organs on a
chip are and again I want to preface
this discussion of a fact and I'm an
analytical chemist amount of biologists
that it's so maybe folks that are
listening to this presentation will
hopefully be able to explain maybe some
of the intimate details a little bit
better than I can in terms of the
biology but what I want to do is just
give a high-level overview and where I
see the potential of this technology
going and so organs on a chip or as we
sometimes call micro physiological
systems are basically micro fluidics
devices
which we're one is able to or attempts
to basically put cell culture and
simulate physiological activities
mechanics and things that occur in
various organs or organ systems and so
as I had mentioned earlier this is
really about the convergence of lab on
ships with cell biology which has a lot
of potential to permit the study of
human physiology in an Oregon specific
context and introducing novel models for
in vitro multicellular human organisms
and so one can see a potential of being
able to look at various organ models
simultaneously and what I have listed
here are a few of them that are actually
being actively studied in this
particular arena and so you can look at
things like lung models which focus on
pulmonary inflammation or infections
liver toxicity you know again tox is a
major concern drug development and
discovery and so having the ability to
to look at the look at screen different
molecules for toxicity is extremely
important also there's mechanisms around
the blood-brain barrier which is a
crucial biological interface it really
has to do with drug transport delivery
and of course drug safety then there's
also models around the gastrointestinal
the GI tract which can emulate gut
biology disease and toxicity and then we
can also look at skin effects so looking
at corrosion and irritation sensitive
sensitive photographic
and finally cardiovascular and so
there's you know any number of different
physiological systems which could
potentially be evaluated and are being
evaluated and again this is a short list
that
you know I've put here but there's
there's obviously other ones that
potentially could be evaluated and
assessed as well so giving a little bit
of context so this isn't something that
is sort of off of everybody's radar it's
actually starting to get a lot of
funding now and in around 2010 the NIH
and the FDA co-founded the advanced
regulatory sciences initiative which and
then DARPA which is the Defense Advanced
Research Projects Agency shortly
thereafter joined in and basically the
focus was really on how to you know
evolve this technology even further and
I'll get into the why you know we would
want to do this or where I see the
potential of this going but recently
there's been quite a few awards totaling
around 15 million dollars per year to
develop these micro physiological
systems and platforms to model human
disease now I might add that there's a
lot of different potential platforms out
there and I think that's the challenge
right now and certainly with new
technology there's always a risk that
you if you invest it may not be around
tomorrow so I think that's also you know
a bit of a challenge in but I think
there's some ways to go about that as
well which I'll get into a little bit
later into the discussion and then and
as I'd mentioned before potentially
multiple organ models can be evaluated
simultaneously and so where I see this
technology going is is really is really
building you know eventually building an
end-to-end platform for discovery and
development so we start basically in
looking at different targets so in drug
development often you know we're looking
at different molecules and trying to
figure out which ones you know meet the
criteria or best meet the criteria to
move on and introduce into the various
clinical phases of course toxicity
is a major concern so we want to make
sure you know that's the number one
concern we want to make sure that there
aren't any safety concerns to patients
by taking any of these medications and
then of course once you've chosen a
molecular entity to develop then you get
into really looking at ok what is the
clinical efficacy you know the dosing
and things like that biomarkers and you
know the bioavailability and and so I
think you know at least for me where I
see this is you know if this technology
if we can learn from this technology you
know or get more you know learn more
intimate details about human physiology
via this technology and if we can
maintain these models then I think you
know this has a lot of potential
especially during the lifecycle of a
product where maybe we look at different
formulations we look at different dosing
regimes and things like that so I think
this has again a really a lot of
potential so as far as where we are with
this technology you know I think we're
we're kind of at the early stages of
thinking about complex physiology now I
think there's a lot of companies out
there and I won't get into the companies
that are actually involved because I
don't want to sort of give the
impression one is better than the other
but certainly if folks are interested we
can talk offline about this but I think
in general there's there's different
there's a lot of different platforms
being developed and different approaches
to this technology which involves
multiple interacting cell types with an
organ and I think you know certainly one
of the challenges is that the complexity
often requires a trade-off and
throughput and so you know with the you
know essentially what you're looking at
our microfluidic cells that need to be
controlled different parameters need to
be controlled simultaneously
so things like media flow temperature
etc and so really if the more questions
that you're trying to answer I think you
know the the you know the more impact it
has on the throughput and certainly
tends to slow things down now I think
there's there's a way to circumvent this
as well and there are people that are
looking at this from a different
perspective and maybe looking at
multiple chips simultaneously as opposed
to just a single chip and then I think
one of the major challenges is also the
cell sourcing of the primary cells you
know to human tissue and those can be
difficult to obtain and and of course
you want a model around and be able to
differentiate between healthy and
diseased states and so being able to get
access to stem cells and it's obviously
a challenge but I think most importantly
I think you know consistent sourcing is
really it's difficult as I'd mentioned
there's a number of players in the space
right now and the list is ever-expanding
which are trying to emulate a wide range
of tissues and organ systems that
oftentimes you know employ different
approaches and so what we'll eventually
have to see in the end is some level of
standardization or platforming I mean
it's it's it's impossible that we have
you know let's say hundreds of different
approaches but again I think certainly
where the focus will be is a little more
let's say agnostic to the specific
technology that's being provided by a
different vendor but more on the
approaches and how we validate these
approaches and these models and I'm
going to get into that a little later in
the presentation and so in the end I
think what's really needed is really a
symbiotic environment where you have a
feedback loop that's created between
research institutions biotechnology and
pharma and health authorities as well to
you know for these for this technology
to evolve
and eventually reach widespread
applications and again I think the focus
will be on platforms that a platform
agnostic approaches and so again how do
we if we take a technology how do we
validate that how do we show that its
robust how do we show that it's reliable
I think that in the end is going to be
you know the ultimate arbiter and you
know in addition to the question that is
being asked of the technology so what I
want to do is get into some of the
intrinsic challenges and encountered in
drug discovery and development and why
we even want to consider this technology
in the first place
as most of you probably know at least
that work in the industry pharmaceutical
research and development efforts are
often both inefficient and suffer from a
high attrition rate of drug candidates
within the clinical phase of development
and this number 95% baby varies a little
bit from company to company but if you
really look at the failure rates quite
high and so you know the number of drugs
that actually come to market is a
representation of many failures as well
so so obviously there's a driver to
increase the odds and what this what
this basically you know is indicating is
that you know we don't know enough about
the human biology and the human
physiology and so being able to use
technology such as organ on a chip and
of course there's others that maybe are
being considered but again I think you
know the rationale for pursuing this
type of technology again is addressing
the very specific problem of the high
attrition rate of drug that occurs in
drug development and what we see is most
drug trials either fail to meet their
expected expected end points or show
minimal statistical differentiation
between active and placebo so
speaks to the efficaciousness or they're
just not let's say significantly better
than what's out there as well which is
now important criteria and then
certainly there's other instances where
failures may happen for safety reasons
and usually you know the talks studies
you know we do tested in animals and
again I think this is also another
potentially another means of avoiding
maybe animal testing and being able to
get some immediate reads on tox which
wouldn't otherwise occur through
traditional means and so again as I've
indicated this is clearly a fundamental
there's clearly a fundamental
understanding of need to understand drug
product properties and drug development
and entry phases the development as well
as accruing knowledge regarding the
specific mechanisms of disease and so I
I think the the data management piece
that I kind of spoke to it to be any of
the talk is really important in this as
well you know drug companies are
generating a lot of data and and Madana
that's generated both successful data
and fail you know failed studies I think
has equal relevance in terms of learning
and understanding and so I think in the
end the companies that are best able to
manage the data are gonna have a
significant advantage over the other
company so you know maybe that's a
separate discussion for another time but
again you know I think the revolution
that's occurring data is Sciences which
I sort of preface this talk as real and
I know certainly with any onsen we're
trying to make efforts to address it so
in terms of the future state I mean
clearly we want to look at alternative
approaches and technologies to increase
the productivity and success of ongoing
drug development efforts I mean it's not
good for us and it's not good for the
patients either you know so certainly I
think at the end if we can bring more
or drugs to patients and more therapies
to patients that's that's that's a
win-win situation for everybody so
assuming that much of the prior
knowledge from drug development and
trial efforts could be aggregated in
some form of management system it's been
proposed that systematic modeling and
simulation based trial designs could
enhance the odds for successful
commercialization of new drug entities
and to that end the application of micro
physiological systems or organs on chips
for development and discovery which can
enhance you know the enhanced in vitro
models can be then used to stimulate and
predict in vivo processes and all this
is starting to show a lot of potential
right now it has a ways to go but
certainly it's starting to show a lot of
potential so assuming that reliable in
vitro models could be developed there's
I think there's certain several valuable
outcomes that could immediately be
visualized so the obvious ones are
enhanced mechanistic and understanding
of disease states and then of course as
I alluded to earlier they improved and
more efficient selection of drug
candidates and then I think what's
what's really important as well as the
decreased reliance on animal testing and
a more humane framework for animal
research and of course improved clinical
outcomes and then the most important I
think of all really is more therapeutic
options for patients and so you know
while the utilization of MPs based
technologies could someday reap enormous
scientific and regulatory benefits for
patients now there's still certain
barriers that must be overcome which are
impactful to the evolution and future
implementation of these technologies
so in terms of next steps I've listed
here some assumptions and so I think
some important assumptions include more
careful exploration of drug properties
early in development is critical you
know so really we're speaking about the
develop ability and so again I think
some of these technologies I think
potentially help us here and then to
really to allow for more efficient
planning during the early phases of drug
development there's a need for the
accrual of disease and trial knowledge
from across various development programs
so again the data management topic is
extremely important you know what have
we learned from the past and and how can
we leverage that to help us in the
future so the data management then
enables agility efficiency and proactive
decision making in the end it helps us
make better choices about the active
moieties and molecules that we we choose
to pursue and develop into hopefully
commercial drugs so in terms of modeling
I mean there's there's already a lot of
modeling that does occur and and these
you know these are these the modeling
itself is certainly something that's
recommended by the FDA and is a
potentially valuable tool to improve the
predictability of and productivity in
the drug development process and so you
know there's a few different approaches
here so there's the system biology
approach which you know basically you're
mathematically representing biological
system at the molecular level and
overlaying that with pathological
perturbations so these are what we call
physiologically based models and this is
kind of where the organ on a chip sort
of resides and so looking at you know
can we simulate it you know in vivo
activities and created an in vitro model
through the use of those chips
and then there's the semi mechanistic in
the empirical models
I think the semi mechanistic tries to
simplify some of the biological simplify
the biology enough to describe what the
data is telling you and then of course
there's the empirical models that really
are just data-driven and they just kind
of tell you well it either works or a
dozen but it doesn't really have as much
lets it's not it doesn't have any strong
attachment to do the biology so to speak
and so one of the important aspects of
the systems biology model is the
characterization of the relationship
between the biomarkers and the clinical
outcomes and so I think this certainly
is something that is already being
studied and but I think again
technologies that can allow us to maybe
look at this of a more high-throughput
sort of perspective and B allow us to
screen more agents I think is going to
be extremely helpful and so you know
within the microfluidic construct
there's various bio processes and that
are simulated and the outcomes from
multiple experiments are then overlaid
with mathematical models that estimate
or predict in vivo performance and then
these parties mathematical parameters
that can be continually refined as
either existing data is is is obtained
or reassessed or becomes available so
the regulatory considerations so I think
you know certainly once you've decided
to sort of jump in into the ocean of
organs on a chip I think what you will
find beyond just the you know once you
get beyond just this science of it
there's there certainly an important
regulatory consideration that needs to
be discussed and developed and so that
narrative I think is it's probably still
I think it's you know it still has a
ways to go and again I think you know
any new technology
that you were introducing ultimately has
to be understood by certainly regulatory
authorities and the reviewers and also
it's it's it's also held up and compared
against you know orthogonal methods or
existing technologies that are let's say
readily available or widely accepted as
standard tools and so again there's
always a little bit of a threshold that
you have to overcome in order to
introduce the new technology now let's
not say that's isn't impossible and
certainly isn't but if it again I think
you you have to do a lot more let's say
convincing in some ways in the beginning
and educating I think is the most
important aspect of being able to
educate the authorities on how this is
applied and and why this is meaningful
so owing to the fact that these are new
and evolving technologies there's really
no regulations that exist for use of
organs on a chip and drug testing so
toxicity and piqué testing require the
use of specific animal models for
specific periods of time which requires
that the technology be sufficiently
evolved and understood to displace these
traditional practices so considering
that organs on a chip are our type of
analytical instrument for the purpose of
drug testing several I think there's
several current regulations that could
be applied to their development and
implementation and so things like
chronic toxicity testing requires
compliance with good laboratory practice
regulations which includes equipment
calibration validation qualification
commercial drug identification and assay
test instruments must also comply with
IC hq2 which is basically a guideline
that describes validation of analytical
procedures and then traditional I think
even in
this context I think traditional
validation parameters such as accuracy
and precision while they may not apply
specifically to this technology you know
we still have to show that that we can
you know create models that are
sufficiently robust so you know again
you know validation and in the classical
sense for now go method may not follow
the same trajectory for or gonna chip so
again while validation parameter such as
accuracy and precision may not be
applicable for mbss as validation
protocol design and results should be
geared towards demonstrating
reproducible results so you know you
want to make sure that each time you you
use this technology you know with
certain agents and things like that that
you get reproducible results and then I
think what's what sometimes people
forget and I think this kind of goes
into certainly late development and
commercial is the maintenance of these
models and I think you know potentially
they can be a very strong tool to
address questions that oftentimes come
up during the lifecycle of products so
you know to sort of give you a quick
example you know often times we're
changing vendors for materials and
things can happen things can you know
sometimes the chemical and physical
properties can change slightly and we
need to understand that and so and need
to understand whether that's it's an
important outcome and so again I think
if we if we have models that we can
leverage that can you know tell us if
there's an you know a real significant
or important in vivo impact you know
that's I think that's important the FDA
runs you know voluntary qualification
programs for biomarkers clinical outcome
assessments and animal models and so you
know the program helps sponsor and
develop such tools for the purposes of
drug development so the formal process
involves consultation with the FDA and a
review with qualification of procedures
for the doll
tool and of course the goat well at
least for me it goes without saying that
organs ownership can be a useful
addition to this program which helps
companies implement the technology
during the early phases of development
so the modeling is I mean the in vitro
models I mean the real purpose is it's
really intended to handle future risk
evaluation and so alternative methods
need to fulfill you know sort of the fit
for purpose criteria for regulatory
acceptance and so the EMA you know which
is the European Medicines Agency
basically gave out three criteria so a
method needs to be valid meaning it has
standardized protocol and clear readouts
and further it needs to be reliable
relevant and validated by recognized
institutions second the method should
generate new and meaningful data or
replace an existing method with the same
or better results so again you know
you're always gonna be up with you know
I'm sort of proving that you know your
method is that at least as good as the
existing one or hopefully even better
and you know some of this I think has
you know probably has some relevance to
standard business practices of various
companies and so it can be a different
discussion depending on the company
you're working with and then finally
what's expected is that the new method
must have been applied in parallel but
independently to accepted method in a
regulatory decision-making process so
again you have to you know with a new
technology you have to certainly
compared it against orthogonal methods
or methods which are standard for the
industry and so in order to achieve
these criteria than the qualification of
the equipment operating the device
according to the standard installation
operating and performance qualification
is required the generation of reliable
reproducible and robust data
needs to be assured by hearin Stu rules
of good cell culture practice so again
organs on a chip you know we're talking
about tissue and things like that so the
use of qualified cells and tissue
sources is extremely important and again
I think that's sort of an intrinsic
challenge at this point with with the
inflammation implementation of this
technology but again that's something
that will I think improve over time and
then the improvement of existing models
and assays towards closer recapitulation
and in vivo physiology it's also been
recommended so you know certainly the
closer we can get to to predicting
physiology the better and so so defining
I think then the critical regulatory
gaps which can be addressed by NPS is
essential to define the biological and
functional features of the model system
so really also you know highlighting
what you know what is it what is what is
the question that's being addressed and
you know certainly there's always gaps
that we encounter in development and so
I think certainly if you're going to
introduce new technology the thought is
is that you're hopefully addressing a
gap that couldn't otherwise be answered
through standard practices and then I
think certainly in the application of
these technologies there's an
expectation that a library of reference
compounds for qualification would be
used so there's certain compounds that
would be specific to certain disease
states and things like that and so
that's something that I think is an
expectation that you know if you if
you're going to introduce a technology
or your version of this technology that
it it's you know it can at least be
referenced and compared against known
compounds that are well characterized
and well understood and then of course
again which goes
sort of without saying is that the
scientific basis needs to be properly
described so this thing you know so with
the technology that you're using or the
type of model that you're trying to
introduce into your development or
discovery
you know this includes information
around the biological and physiological
processes that are being modeled and why
they're thought to be relevant you know
for the substrates adverse affect so and
so finally then the the validation
roadmap so if you look at you know how
this would sort of evolve and you know
where we would end up being I think
there's a couple different sort of
outcomes that potentially could occur
here so the first one basically systems
aiming for safety and efficacy testing
during drug development might be
qualified through the US FDA drug
development tools so the DDT
qualification program and this is
especially true for systems requiring
fast-track validations such as those mps
models targeting compounds of diseases
that cannot be tested using you know
techniques currently available and so
this applies especially to novel about
pharmaceuticals specially designed for
humans and maybe those that are
irrelevant to to testing in animals to
begin with and so here you know a clear
description of the manner and the
purpose and the use of the systems as
well as its limitations is really
mandatory and then the validation I
think I've kind of lewd to this
validation of individual biomarkers
under the biomarker qualification
program on a specific NPS may be the key
step to our qualification acceptance as
a tool for therapeutic development as
well and then finally qualifying an NPS
for specific context or use as as a drug
development tool will eventually lead
to a tool which may be considered
product independence and may be used for
efficacy testing and development
programs for multiple investigational
drugs for the same disease or condition
that's being targeted so additionally
you know I think I kind of alluded to
earlier in the talk to important
consideration about replacing or the aim
to replace animal testing with in vitro
models and so so the MPS you know that
named or aim to do this need to be you
know at least oblige the respective OAC
guidelines so that's the Organisation
for Economic Cooperation and Development
and in the process of identifying that
you know hazard potential is highly
standardized and it's recommended that
the MPs adhere to these guidelines
there's a guidance document on
validation and international acceptance
of new and updated test methods for
hazard assessment so you know again this
is a critical criteria and then
high-quality data from MPs that are
consistent with the results derived from
other approaches will provide initial
evidence for the reliability but again a
certain amount of care must be taken
when comparing results gained from human
base MPs with animal studies as as the
latter might lack you know a certain
level of sensitivity and specificity so
again we're sort of in this conundrum of
you know we're comparing against
existing tools which yeah may have their
own limitations to begin with and so
again you know how do you you know you
need to be able to differentiate between
your tool and something which you know
may be lacking to begin with which is
not uncommon and then of course doing
then the cross validation trials to go
to to assess you know the baselines
would be constructed
and so and then I think you know the
demonstration that these new devices can
be used to identify compounds that have
failed in clinical trials would generate
more confidence in these technologies as
well so again I mentioned you know it's
it's certainly success is important but
also failure so I think if if you really
have a technology that can differentiate
between both or at least to a high level
be able to predict the outcomes I think
you have something that's extremely
powerful so some final remarks on this
technology we've we've covered a lot of
ground and and so what I want to do on
this final slide is is really kind of
highlight some of the at least for me
the important elements of this
technology and and sort of where we need
to go and sort where we are at this
point so you know as I had mentioned I
think this is kind of more for the
laboratory people but you know the organ
on a chip is really a successor to
lab-on-a-chip so it's again it's a micro
fluidics technology so that that means
certain things I think to certain people
and certainly as an analytical chemist
to me it means you know looking at it as
there's an analytical tool and applying
it as as I might typically would I was
an analytical chemist and so and I've
certainly brought up some some
perspectives on validation you know and
what that might mean and so again you
know it's really the convergence of
lab-on-a-chip and cell biology and and
so we're again where I see this as
having a lot of potential is if we can
emulate human physiology and creating in
vitro models you know we can really then
directly address this high attrition
rate
kurz and drug development and ideally
get more products to patients and I
think that's you know for me that's the
number one goal I mean we do a lot of we
spend a lot of time a lot of people
spend a lot of time doing a lot of good
science but it's it's again it's a
significant challenge and you know the
physiology is this extremely complex
machine and so again I think if we have
technologies that can maybe give us some
you know a better read on what might
happen I think that's gonna be a benefit
to everybody and as I'd mentioned
already these models are starting to
show a lot of potential I think
certainly there's still some work to be
done but again it's I think it's moving
in the right direction and and certainly
there's a lot of different valuable
outcomes that can occur you know
obviously beyond just the the attrition
rate that I've described earlier in the
talk but you're really getting an
enhanced mechanistic understanding of
disease states
I think you know certainly if we knew
everything there was to know about
disease we wouldn't be you know
development wouldn't be so difficult but
it is it's challenging and of course
then being able to quickly I think
what's equally important is really
improving and being more efficient about
the drug candidates that we choose to
develop so really looking at the develop
ability you know are these are these
really fit for purpose are they are they
gonna meet the end point again we you
know and certainly in pharma we want to
focus on the things that we think are
going to work or have a high probability
of working so if we can quickly kind of
separate out the bad apples that would
be you know a good outcome and then I
think as I mentioned you know decreased
reliance and animal testing I think
that's important it's certainly a more
humane way to go about doing clinical
and pharmaceutical research of course if
we can
if we understand the disease states and
the mechanisms behind it as e states
better that we can improve the clinical
outcomes and then have more therapeutic
options for patients and I think as I
mentioned before the what's really
critical and this is that you know we
have a feedback loop between the
research institutions that are really
driving this technology and developing
this technology and with biotech and
pharma and health authorities because
again you know a lot of times it's about
framing and and certainly you have a lot
of let's say really top-notch scientists
that are working on this type of
technology but if you ask them you know
what are the typical questions that
maybe we're confronted with in pharma I
think a lot of them would be
hard-pressed to answer that question I
think it takes certainly you need to
have experience in the industry and have
gone through some of the challenges and
trials and tribulations to to really
understand that in intimately so I think
again really fine tuning you know the
the applications is is critical and that
needs to really occur through dialogue
between research institutions and the
pharma industry and of course the health
authorities as well you know in terms of
you know how do we make this viable and
how do we show that it's reliable and
that it's robust and it's gonna give us
accurate and predictive information and
then certainly you know at the end
there's you know again an absence of
regulatory guidance around these you
know regulations and so of course this
develops I think there's there's gonna
have to be some guidance as written and
I'm actually a member of the IQ
consortium it's the innovation quality
consortium and there's an MPS affiliate
which I'm involved in and in what we're
trying to do in this regard is really
sort of look at this technology agnostic
li not really focus on specific vendors
or let's say developers of this
technology but really look at well how
would you apply this you know and how
how can we make this work for everybody
so again I think those are things that
need to be worked out and finally I
think we get to the end of the
conversation but I think at the
beginning of the presentation I was
asking if this was a revolution and drug
development and at least for me I think
the answer is yes but we have a ways to
go so this with anything worthwhile even
revolutions take time so thank you for
your time and thank you dr. yarder for
that informative presentation I'd also
like to think elaborate for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to remind everyone
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through May 2019
as a final reminder dr. Yoder will
follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
and thank you for joining us we'll see
you next time bye bye